The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Welcome back to 6.890.
Today we're going to look at
a bunch of different graph
problems, that is, their
unifying feature is
they're problems on graphs.
We're going to look
at vertex cover,
we're going to look at
vertex coloring of graphs,
and we're going to look at some
ordering problems on graphs,
and I think, one more,
orientations of graphs.
So these are all going to
be some kind of constraint
that we place on the
graph or something we
want to do with the graph.
This is sort of a
miscellaneous lecture.
We've spent a lot of
time talking about 3SAT,
most recently Hamiltonicity, and
before all that, 3-partition,
which are the most popular,
most useful, I would say,
ways of doing NP
hardness reductions.
But there are few
others that are
good to know that are sometimes
relevant, and so this is that.
Each one is a little
bit smaller in content,
so we're just going to
lump them all together.
So we'll start
with vertex cover.
We saw this slide
from lecture four,
I think, from planar 3SAT.
Lichtenstein proved
planar vertex covers hard.
Vertex cover, remember,
is this problem.
You want to choose
a set of vertices,
let's say k vertices,
to hit all the edges.
A different way of thinking
about this problem-- and a lot
of these problems, you can think
of in a more logical context,
formulas and so on-- this is
essentially a form of 2SAT
with k true variables.
It's even a positive 2SAT.
Because essentially,
you could think
of there being a
variable for each vertex,
whether you choose
it, and then the edge
is just stating the
constraint that you should
choose one or the
other endpoints
and so that's a 2SAT constraint.
And 2SAT is easy,
but when you say,
I want to solve 2SAT with only
setting k of the variables
to be true, then it becomes this
NP hard problem vertex cover.
And so we have-- This was a
reduction from planar 3SAT
to planar vertex cover, so
we know this problem is hard.
Let's use it for some
things, and let's also
prove some even more
related versions are hard.
So this one was already
maximum degree 3,
if we have some unused copies,
we'll get degree 2 vertices,
but certainly every vertex
is at most degree 3.
And it was planar, so
that's already cool.
Planar max degree 3 is hard.
Some polynomial versions
to be careful of if you're
using vertex cover
as a starting point.
One is what I call
exact vertex cover.
Each edge is incident to
exactly one chosen vertex.
So the vertex cover could
be one or the other.
If you have exclusively, or
between those two, it's easy.
And another version,
sort of the duel
between vertices
and edges, one might
call it edge cover,
which would be choose
k edges to hit all vertices.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't exact
edge cover perfect matching?
PROFESSOR: Exact vertex cover
is perfect matching, thank you.
This is also essentially
maximum cardinality
matching because the more
you can be a matching,
the more efficient
you're going to be,
and then every isolated
vertex after you
have a maximum
cardinality matching,
you just have to cover
those with one more.
So both of these
reduce to matching.
So it's obvious in
hindsight, but be careful,
if you're ever doing vertex
cover, not to accidentally do
one of these.
OK, so this morning's.
Here's a cool version
of vertex cover.
It can be useful.
We'll use it in a moment to
prove a particular problem
hard, connected vertex cover.
So usually, with a
vertex cover, you
imagine you're just
grabbing vertices
from all over the graph.
With connected vertex
cover, you require
that the chosen vertices
induce a connected subgraph.
So this is not, obviously,
easier or harder as a problem.
It's more restrictive
on the cover,
but we can prove that
it's NP hard by reduction
from this problem.
And so in particular,
we'll get that it's NP
hard for planar max
degree 4 graphs.
So here's the reduction.
I think this reduction
is quite cool,
because it uses planarity.
It may not be necessary
to use planarity,
but this reduction definitely
uses planarity in a rich way.
So even if you were trying to
prove this without planarity,
it would be more awkward.
So, suppose you
have a planar graph
and you want to find a minimum
vertex cover in this graph.
We're going to modify
the graph in this way.
This is yet another
Garey and Johnson paper.
So you can see the original
faces of the graph,
and then for each
face, we're going
to add in sort of
a copy of the face.
So also the outside face
gets this kind of curvy copy.
And so in particular,
at every vertex
there's now going to be
five copies of the vertex.
One on the one incident face,
one on the other incident
face, and then for
every one of these
we're going to have an
extra leaf hanging off.
Why leaves?
Leaves are really cool, or
really annoying, or whatever.
They're very forceful in
the case of vertex cover.
If you look at a leaf--
So here's a leaf.
It's connected to some vertex
that's presumably not a leaf,
otherwise there'd be
an isolated component.
It's never useful to put
this in the vertex cover.
If you decide to put
this in the vertex cover,
you might as well
choose this guy instead,
because this covers more.
It covers all the edges that
this one did, namely that one
edge, and some other edges.
Maybe it was already
in the vertex cover.
Then it wasn't minimum.
Then you got smaller.
But you can assume there is
an optimal solution where
you never put leaves
in the vertex cover.
What that means is, wherever
we add a leaf like this,
it basically forces
you-- It lets
you know that you might as well
have this in the vertex cover.
There is an optimal solution
where this is in the vertex
cover, because the only other
option is that this one is,
and then you can move it over.
So these vertices on
the copies of the faces,
those are all forced to
be in the cover, which
means this entire copy of the
face, the inset copy the face,
is completely covered
already, plus these edges
are covered connecting
the inner copy of the face
to the original face.
So there's still stuff to cover.
So in particular, it's
still interesting to put
one of the original
vertices in the cover.
That would cover these
three, now every edge
got cut into three parts.
So this would cover
1/3 of the edge.
The idea is, if you
put this in the cover
and you cover those
three guys, we still
have to cover these
two, and we'll
do that by putting this
vertex in the cover.
Because one of these two
has to be in in order
to cover this middle
edge, and the idea
is that you'll be able to
just put one of them in.
You'll be able to put
exactly one of these two
on every subdivided edge, if
and only if there is a vertex
cover of the right size.
So if I do the arithmetic
here, the claim
is we added exactly 5 times
the original number of edges
to the optimal vertex cover.
5 because for every original
edge we added 2 here,
2 here, and then 1 of these too.
So there were 6 vertices
around this edge that we added,
and if we can cover, say,
this edge using that vertex
or cover this edge
using that vertex, which
is the same as saying that this
original edge is covered by one
side or the other, then we
only need one of these two guys
and then we'll get away
with just 5 per edge.
So the original thing has
a vertex cover of size k
if and only if this new thing
has a vertex cover size of k
plus 5 times the
number of edges.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What stops you
from taking one of the--
PROFESSOR: Taking both
of these, for example?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's a good
thing to worry about.
Maybe you take both
and then you don't
have to choose either
one, so it doesn't
look like a vertex cover, but
this is a similar argument
to the leaves.
If you choose both
of these guys,
because you know that
the other four are there,
you can always move one
of them to the vertex.
So you'll get a
recover vertex cover.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
fives times the edges
plus the number for
vertices because you also
have to cover the
leaves off the vertices?
PROFESSOR: These leaves?
AUDIENCE: No, the one
with the vertices.
PROFESSOR: Oh, these ones.
Whoops.
Oh, so it looks
like they're always
increasing the degree to 4.
Connected vertex, however, is
actually an important problem.
People think about it a lot.
For some kind of
networking applications,
you want to build some backbone
that can reach everybody,
you need a connected network.
But Garey and Johnson's
original motivation
for introducing that problem is
rectilinear Steiner tree, also
an important networking problem.
Steiner tree is about
usually you imagine
you're given some space where
you can build a network,
and you're given some things
that you want to interconnect.
So maybe you're building a
new city around some existing
houses, you're given
some points in the plane
that represent houses.
Now you want to build roads
to connect them all together.
You want to minimize the amount
of roads you have to build,
so you're going to build a tree.
And Steiner tree means that
you can add intersections
wherever you want, as opposed
to a minimum spanning tree,
where you can only turn
at the given vertices.
If you have some points
like this in the plane,
the best way to
connect them together
in the Euclidean metric is
to have-- I didn't draw it
super well-- to have
120 degree angles at all
the intersections,
something you can prove.
Here, we're thinking about
rectilinear Steiner tree, which
is the Manhattan version,
where you're only
allowed to draw orthogonal
connections, like that.
So you can still
add extra vertices
if you want to minimize
the total length
of these connections given
endpoints in the plane.
This problem is NP hard,
and you can prove it
in a very simple way.
This is the reduction
from the previous problem.
So the first step
is-- And the reason
they care about max degree
4 in the previous problem
is to draw the graph in the
plane in orthogonal drawings.
So every vertex becomes
a point, every edge
become some orthogonal path
connecting two vertices.
We've done that in
previous proofs.
So now everything's drawn in
the plane, something like this.
And that each
vertex, we're going
to erase a little
circle of radius 2,
and then that leaves
a bunch of segments,
and the segments
connected together,
and now we're just going to
place along those segments
a whole bunch of points.
And so the idea is that
the Steiner tree should
connect all those together, and
then it's left with a choice.
And those are all going
to be distance 1 apart.
Then it's left with a choice
of where to connect things
together, which vertices.
So a little bit more
formally, each of these edges
is going to be scaled up by a
huge factor, 4 times n squared,
where n, I think, is the
dimension of the n by n grid.
So these are the original
grids, the dash lines.
Originally, when you draw
it on a graph, on a grid,
you imagine probably
these are unit length.
Scale it up to the length
4n squared and then the rule
is, wherever you have an
integer point along that line,
add a dot.
And so they will be spaced
with distances of 1.
Over here, we have
distances of 2
between the vertex, which is
not actually a point in the set,
and here.
And so distance of 4 between
any pairs of those points.
Because these
distances are so huge,
you never want to connect from
here to anywhere else that's
not at this local intersection.
OK?
And there's an
argument about that,
looking at these regions
of where you could possibly
want to go, and there's only
those endpoints in there
and these are really
cheap to connect.
So it really only pays to
connect things in between.
So basically, you
show that you're
forced to do all the
unit length connections,
and now you just have to
make the thing connected.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Why 2?
PROFESSOR: Because
2 is bigger than 1.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I guess with the
vertex covers that you'd want
to fill in that whole cross?
But maybe there's a fear
that you would just connect--
PROFESSOR: No.
You won't fill in the whole
cross in the vertex cover.
Let me tell what
you're going to do.
This proof is-- I mean, the
reduction is super simple,
but the argument is confusing.
So here's the idea.
So there's essentially
two things going on,
but let's first
think about the case
where I give you a connected
vertex cover of some size.
What I'm going to do is
first-- or you can think
of it in either order--
I'm, in particular,
going to connect all
the vertices together.
Now, there's no particular
reason to connect the vertices,
but I'm just going to do it
anyway, or think about doing it
anyway, by a spanning tree.
So there's lots of
redundant connectivity here.
I don't need to
connect this, to this,
to this all the way around.
I can drop one of
those connections
because I just need
to be connected,
I just need a spanning tree.
And in general, there are v
vertices to connect together,
and each one of them costs
2, in a certain sense.
To connect a vertex to
an incident edge costs 2.
And so there are v minus 1
edges in the spanning tree,
so I'm going to pay that.
On the other hand, I
also knew that every edge
is connected to some vertex.
That's the vertex
cover constraint,
and so every edge is
going to pay 2 in order
to connect to a vertex.
So the weird thing here is the
involvement of the vertices,
even though there's
no point there.
That's funny.
Maybe we could add a point there
and make it a little clearer,
but instead of thinking
about connections from edges
to edges, which
would cost 4, that's
sort of the wrong way to think
about it, because there's
two things going on.
One is just to get the edges
to connect to something,
and then there's getting
all that something's
connected together.
So this is sort of a
spanning tree thing,
and this is more of the actual
vertex cover constraint.
Together, they give
the connector vertex
cover constraint.
It would be impossible
for a Steiner tree
to do one without the other.
But essentially-- I mean,
I'm going to wave my hands
a little bit here,
but you work it out.
In all cases, the number
of connections you need
is exactly this if
there's a vertex cover,
and this will have to go up
if there isn't a vertex cover.
That was vertex cover.
Let's do coloring.
This will be, I think, more fun.
So first, let's prove
that coloring is hard.
So in general, in
the coloring problem,
also called chromatic
number, you're given a graph
and you're given a number k.
You want to color the
vertices of the graph using
k different colors,
so that's a mapping
from the vertices
to the colors such
that no edge is monochromatic.
So you want a mapping, let's
call it c, from the vertices
to 1 up to k such that for
every edge, let me call it vw,
the color of v does not
equal to color of w.
So that's the no
monochromatic edge constraint.
It's usual coloring
for vertex coloring.
You could also talk about
edge coloring and so on,
and this problem is easy.
If k is 1, then you
better not have any edges.
It's easy if k is 2.
That's bipartiteness testing.
You can just greedily
color and you can never
make a mistake unless the
graph isn't bipartite.
But it becomes hard
when k equals 3,
so that's a fun transition.
And so here is why vertex
3-coloring is hard as proved
by Garey, Johnson, Stockmeyer.
Reduction from 3SAT.
So we have, on the one
hand, variable gadget.
We're going to represent
XI and XI bar like this.
I mean, coloring should
feel a lot like SAT.
In fact, you might think
of this as xor 2SAT,
if you think of xor as
the not equals operator.
But it's over ternary logic.
So this gets back to
a question from class.
What about ternary logic?
You can think of 3-colorings
like ternary logic,
just like on the problem set.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to have one
copy of this gadget.
I call it a colors gadget.
It's just a triangle,
and so all three colors
must appear on that triangle.
We don't know in what order,
but we don't really care.
We can just define the one.
The color that this guy's
assigned, we'll call it red.
It could be 1, 2, or 3,
but it doesn't matter.
Call the color that this
guy's assigned green,
and this one blue,
and hopefully you're
not sufficiently colorblind to
be unable to distinguish those.
But I did check with
a color blind tester,
they do seem at least
different, but it might
be hard to know the names.
All right.
So this green vertex is
connected to both XI and XI bar
for each of the
variables, which means
they can either be red or blue.
And I want to red to mean
false, blue to mean true.
So that's cool, that's
nice, regular binary logic.
And then we're going to
combine those variables
with this clause gadget.
Clause gadget also has
one node out at the end
here connected to
both green and red,
which forces it to be blue.
But otherwise,
it's kind of free.
So we have instances
of literals.
These don't have to
be the positive forms,
this could be XI bar,
XJ bar, whatever.
And now we're going to
think about coloring.
So let me show you a couple
of possible colorings.
Here's a valid coloring.
It's valid because at least--
This is going to be 3SAT,
so at least one of these should
be true, true means blue.
This guy is blue,
and in general,
what we're doing is
kind of taking an
or of this pair and then an
or of that pair with this one
variable, one
literal, I should say.
And because this is not
red, I can put red here.
Again, all three
colors must appear.
So in general,
what I want to do--
you'll see why in a moment--
is push the reds as far
back as possible.
So if I can put a red or
red here or here, I'm happy,
and I put some other
color over there.
I guess I'll put-- It
doesn't matter which
one is blue or green here.
As long as I can
put red back here,
I can also put red back here.
And it could be if
this one is blue,
I could also put
the red guy here,
and I have the flexibility.
But as long as I can put
red either here or here,
this one will not be red.
And furthermore, I
can make it not green,
and that's what these
constraints tell me.
This vertex should
not be red or green.
That's satisfied here.
And you can show, you
can check all cases,
or just sort of go
through that argument.
The only bad case is
when they're all red,
because then, looking
at this triangle,
the red one has to
be pushed forward.
And then, because this one
is red and this one is red,
again, this red has
to be pushed forward,
but then we have a
red-red adjacency
and that's not allowed.
So that is 3SAT to
vertex 3-coloring.
Cool.
Now, this does not
preserve planarity,
because the colors
gadget is connected
to pretty much everything,
and it does not
preserve bounded degree.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The variable gadget doesn't seem
to be connected to the clause
gadget here.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
I mean, when I
sit right XI here,
I mean it's the same
vertex as one of these.
Yeah.
So if there's n
variables, n clauses,
it's going to be 2n
of these vertices
and then they're shared
among the n clauses.
It's hard to draw,
because actually they're
identified as opposed
to connected by an edge.
Other questions?
All right.
So I think first
we make it planar.
We have a new crossover gadget
for specific to 3-coloring.
Planar 3SAT doesn't seem
to help immediately,
so we're just going
to, because we
have all of these
connections from colors
gadget to everybody,
plug this in whenever
we have an intersection.
And the idea, locally,
is that whatever color
is assigned to this
vertex, x, must
be the same as the color
assigned to this vertex,
x prime, and similarly,
y, and y prime.
And they're free
of each other, you
can do any assignment to
x, any assignment to y,
and this will be satisfiable.
I'll give you some colorings
to give you-- I mean,
this is essentially two
cases, which is either
x and x prime have the
same color as y and y prime
or they have different colors.
So here's the same
color case, you
get this nice
rotational symmetry.
In general, you've
got this wheel pattern
of four triangles, and
you have some color here,
and then that forced these guys
to alternate in the other two
colors available
around that center,
and then it essentially
communicates
the information you need.
It's hard to do sort of
a straight line argument
about why this is the case,
other than to just try
all the possibilities.
But there's, again,
lots of triangles.
So once you know this is red,
you know one of these is green,
and one of them is blue.
Could go one way or the
other at this point.
I think you could actually
do it one way or the other
and just flip all the
greens with blues,
and vice versa, because green
and blue is, in this case,
local to the gadget.
And, anyway, you end up with,
once these two are set red,
these two are forced to
be set red by casework.
Here is the other case, when
xx prime is different from yy
prime, or you could say
x and y are different,
and then, again, it forces
x to propagate through,
y to propagate through.
We still get alternation
here, but now the unused color
is in the center, whereas
before, this picture,
we had the center color was
the color used by all three,
or all four of them.
On the outside
here, it's the color
that's not any of those two.
And, again, it's forced
by playing around.
OK.
So that means we
have a figure here
about how you actually
use this crossover
gadget because there's this
issue of identification,
which is little bit subtle.
So if you have an edge that's
crossed by a bunch of edges,
you intuitively
want to stick this
into each of the crossings.
But because this is copying
the value here to here,
it's really just like
taking this vertex
and pushing it to the
other side of the edge.
So when you throw
in this crossover,
you want to identify the
left vertex of the crossover
with the original
vertex on the left side,
but not identify it
on the right side.
Therefore, overall,
there's still
one edge connecting x and y
because this is essentially
a copy of x, but you still
need that edge to connect to y.
So you don't want to
identify both sides,
you don't want to
identify on neither side,
because that would be two edges.
Identify on one side.
And it's like a vertex
cover, but you just
pick one side for
each edge arbitrarily.
And that is planar vertex
3-coloring not bound
to degree yet.
OK?
Next reduction.
This is in the same paper.
Here's how to
simulate high degree.
I mean, it's pretty intuitive.
Once you have the
ability to copy color,
you can use it to
get high degree.
OK, I'll talk about the actual
degree bound in the moment,
but let's say we're
aiming for max degree 4.
This one, you can actually
argue in a very simple way.
So here's a little gadget.
I claim it makes three
copies of this color,
or two copies of the color at x.
So you've got these
three vertices.
One of them's blue,
one of them's green.
Doesn't matter which is which,
but then this vertex must
be red because of that
triangle, and then this vertex
must be green because
of that triangle,
then this vertex must be blue
because of that triangle,
this one must be red,
and this one must be red.
So that's a really
easy one to argue.
And so, this is not
very interesting,
because we made two copies.
This will simulate
a degree 3 vertex,
which we don't worry about.
But where it gets
interesting, if you just
string a bunch of
these together here,
we end up with five
copies of a single color,
and so you can connect with
a single edge out here,
let's say.
I guess you could even
afford two edges there.
In particular, we can
use this to simulate
one vertex of degree 5 and we
will end up with max degree 4.
Degree 4 Because some of
these vertices have degree 4.
Actually, most of them do.
AUDIENCE: Could you have just
used the crossover gadget
as a high degree gadget?
PROFESSOR: Oh, in a circle.
Yeah, that would
also work, I think.
Do you have a problem?
AUDIENCE: There are degree 7
vertices when you pit together
two of these?
You've moved--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Degree 6.
Yeah.
Well, OK.
So that will give
you max degree 6,
and this gives you max degree 4.
Yeah.
If we do is after
the crossover gadget,
then the crossover
gadget will become happy.
So what's the conclusion?
Planar max degree 4,
3-coloring is hard.
But be careful, max
degree 3, 3-coloring
is easy polynomial time
unless your graph is k4.
So one counter example.
This is always possible.
This is called Burke's
theorem from 1941.
So in general, if you
have max degree delta,
there's a delta coloring unless
a couple of bad things happen.
Odd cycle or a complete graph.
So that's cool.
AUDIENCE: What do
you mean if it's k4
and then it doesn't work?
PROFESSOR: k4
requires four colors.
AUDIENCE: But then when finding
whether or not there's--
PROFESSOR: But k4
has max degree 3.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
polynomial figure out
if there's a 3 colorable?
PROFESSOR: It's
polynomial in all cases,
but I'm saying every
max degree 3 graph is
3 colorable except for k4.
So the decision
problem is, am I k4.
Or I guess, am I not k4 would
be the 3-coloring problem.
AUDIENCE: The word
planar isn't up there.
PROFESSOR: Right, even without
planar, it's polynomial.
Don't need planarity
for that algorithm
for testing for k4ness.
And I didn't check,
but I'm pretty sure.
Usually once the
decision problem is easy,
also the actual coloring
algorithm is easy,
but I didn't check.
I assume there's a polynomial
coloring algorithm, not just
a decision algorithm, but
we should double check
before you cite that result.
AUDIENCE: You can
[INAUDIBLE], make
yourself a [INAUDIBLE] gadget
and then try probing things.
PROFESSOR: Oh, right.
You could reduce
the decision problem
to the actual coloring problem.
You can test whether two
guys have the same color
by a bunch of probes.
OK, so what?
Why graph coloring?
There aren't a ton of
proofs that use coloring,
because usually 3SAT is
simpler because it only
has binary values, but
there are situations
where coloring is helpful.
I have one here that we used in
the context of pushing blocks.
We covered Push-* is hard,
we covered Push-1 is hard,
we covered these two
proofs in that lecture,
and then implied PushPush, but
we didn't talk about Push-X.
Push-X was the version where
you're not allowed to revisit
the same square twice.
Like every time
you leave a square,
it falls down into
the abyss behind you,
so you can never step
on that square again.
So our hardness proof
for that uses coloring,
and I think it's instructive
not because I care especially
about Push-1X but it seems
like a general approach
to representing color.
So good to see the gadgets.
First, a simple idea is that,
if I have some planar graph
I want to take an Euler
tour-- a tour that
visits every edge
exactly twice--
and I want to do
that in a planar way.
So the idea is, I
don't want my tour
to come down this
way through a vertex
and then later come through
this way in a vertex.
That's a meaningful
thing because I
know that planar
coloring is hard,
so I'm going to
reduce from planar max
degree 4, 3-coloring.
So I've got a planar graph,
I draw it in the plane,
and then relative
to that drawing,
I want to make sure there's
no crossings in my tour
that visits every
edge exactly twice.
These always exist,
simple inductive proof,
start with one vertex,
visit the star around it,
and then just start gluing
these things together.
In the inductive way, you
will get a planar Eulerian
tour, standard trick.
Now we're going
to use that tour.
So here we see an actual
graph in the dashed lines
and then we see the Euler
tour in the red lines,
and the red path is
essentially the tour
taken by the robot that's
pushing the blocks around.
So it's walking around in
some direction somewhere--
I think not drawn here.
Maybe that.
I'm going to break this
apart and I'm going to say,
the robot starts here,
there's an obstacle here,
and the goal is to get here.
So your sole purpose
in this puzzle
is to start here and get
all the way around the loop,
and you're just going to be
able to go along the red path.
But there's some interactions.
There's the blue
arrows, and then there's
the green, wiggly lines
and that's all you'll need.
One of them is an equal
constraint, and one of them
is not equal constraint.
And the idea is that when
you visit a vertex-- so let's
say you start here at u-- I'm
going to pick a color-- 1, 2,
or 3, and there will actually
be three red paths here.
Then those three red paths
will interact with these three
red paths to force equality.
The wiggly lines mean equality.
So I want that
whatever color I've
chosen here is the same as
the color I've chosen here,
because I want u
to have one color,
I'm only allowed to
assign one color to u.
So we're going to look at how
to do that equality constraint.
And then we have these
types of constraints,
which say that the
colors are different,
non-equal, because I
want the color assigned
to u to be different than
the color assigned to v.
And this path is
coming from v so
at this point the color that
you're on, which of the red
rails you're on,
says which color
is assigned to v. You
want that color to be
different from the
color assigned to u.
Then you transition and say, OK.
Now I'm going to
start over and pick
another color between 1 and 3.
And then here, it's constrained
to be equal to this one.
So I think the arrows are
delineating the transitions
from the color.
Here it should all be color
v. Well, that's maybe not so
[INAUDIBLE], but
somewhere along this edge,
you're going to
switch to thinking
about the color v to thinking
about the color of u.
You only need one
color at any moment,
so there will only have to be
three parallel tracks for each
of these things.
That's the high level picture.
Let me tell you actually do it.
So here's this left part
expanded into a slightly more
detailed picture.
Still a bunch of
details to be filled in,
but we see still the non-equal
and the equal gadgets,
just like before, but
here I've explicitly
shown the three tracks.
So we were looking at this
edge before, so let's say here.
Here's where you
choose the color for u.
So we're going to use what
we call a fork gadget.
We've maybe seen something
like this before.
When you come in, you can
choose one of these three paths.
Once you choose,
you can't unchoose.
It's a one-way gadget.
So let's say you
choose path one, that
means that this
vertex u is colored 1.
Then you're going to have some
equal gadget-- these three
paths are connected
over here-- but you'll
be forced that this path is
the same as the one chosen over
here.
We'll get to that one later.
Then you go over
here, you're forced
that among these
three paths, you're
different from the
three paths over here,
because that's going
to be the color v.
And then, you now want to
switch from the u color
to the v color.
So I'm just going to have
some one-way gadgets here
that coalesce these
three wires into one,
and then whatever's next-- Let's
say this is next, v was a leaf.
Then you have a fork, again,
to choose the color for v.
So it's kind of weird, you
get to choose the color
for vertex several times.
Here we're choosing it for u,
here were choosing it again
for u, but they're
combined together
with this equal gadget,
so those two choices
are forced to be the same.
That's the idea.
And then the
non-equal gadgets are
doing the actual
coloring constraint
of no monochromatic edges.
So it looks complicated,
but all you really need
are these things.
Well, and the fork
and the one-way.
Let's do the fork
and the one-way,
because those are easy.
We've basically
seen them before.
Pretty sure we did
this one-way gadget.
You can go from a to
b, but not from b to a.
Cool.
So that means when
I come through here,
I can't back up along some
other path, that would be bad.
And the fork gadget,
this is a two-way fork.
You come in from a and you can
either push this in and then
choose to go to
c, but then you'll
never be able to go to b, or
you can push this down and then
go to b and you'll never
be able to go to c.
So when you make this choice,
you can't undo the choice.
You just chain two
of these together
to make a three-way choice.
And the one-way is to
prevent you from going back
along one of these paths.
So that's the easy part.
Then what about the equal
and the non-equal gadgets?
These are complicated,
but in the end,
they reduce to some
very simple gadgets.
So let's start with
the non-equal gadget.
So we have three possible
color choices for one edge,
for one vertex, and we have
three possible choices down
here for the other vertex.
Together, those vertices
should form the edge e,
and this is written
as e going one way
or e going the other way
and coming from one vertex
and coming from the
other vertex end.
And what we want is
to forbid blue-blue,
or to forbid red-red, or
to forbid orange-orange.
And because this paper was also
printed in black and white,
the dash patterns also
duplicate the color information.
So even if you
lost all color, you
can distinguish
these types of lines.
So we need this gadget, which
we called a manned gadget,
but you should not
have both of these.
And there's a couple
different cases,
depending on the orientation.
But, for example, if
you go from a to b,
you have to push this down.
Which, because this is Push-1,
you only have strength one,
you're not able to push up.
You're not able to traverse
cd anymore if you do a to b.
This is the symmetric
version where,
if you first do b to a, then
that prevents cd traversal.
And its symmetric,
so vice versa, OK?
So that's the gadget
that plugs in here.
And so now we know that, if
we follow the path along 3,
the blue path for
this vertex, we
won't be able to
traverse the blue path.
And so whatever choice
you made here at the fork
has to be different
from this choice.
It's kind of a fun,
non-local effect.
And it doesn't matter,
whoever makes the choice first
will block the choice
for the other guy.
If you had multiple robots
simultaneously doing things,
then it would get
tricky when there's
two robots right here at the
same time, but probably even
then, it would work as long
as everything eventually
gets traversed.
OK.
So then we also need some
limited kinds of crossovers
to make this happen, because we
need to take this orange path.
I don't know why it's orange.
It should be green,
but there you go.
Bring it down here and
then bring it back up.
So that's going to require
the orange path to cross
the red path and the blue path.
Good news.
We know that only
one of these will
be traversed, because the
fork gadget has that property.
If you end up
following the one path,
you know that 2 will not
have to be traversed,
so this is what we called
an xor crossover back when
we were doing pushing blocks.
It's a crossover that
works as long as you only
are visiting it once,
one way or the other way.
So, for example, if you come--
And it's also uni-directional.
So if you come from a,
you can push that down,
but then you won't be
able to go to c or d,
and then you can
leave through b.
And from c, you can
push this over, go to d,
and those are the only cases we
need with various reflections
and rotations.
We either go from
up top to down here,
or we go from right to left
here through that xor crossover.
So you just plug
those crossovers in
and you can get
each of these paths
to where you need
them to be, and you
know that they'll
work because you
won't have to do both of those
traversals, and there you go.
So in general, as long as you
have a NAND gadget and an xor
gadget, then you can do this
to make a not equal gadget.
So there's a lot of pieces
here, but in the end,
it reduces to very few things.
We had a one-way, a
fork, an xor, and a NAND.
If you have those things,
you can simulate 3-coloring
in this planar way.
Now, I didn't cover
one more gadget,
which is the equal gadget.
It's just a more
complicated version
of the non-equal gadget.
So you need to prevent
this one from being
blue when the bottom
one is orange,
you need to prevent this
one from being blue when
the bottom one is
red, and you need
to prevent this one from being
red when that one's orange,
you need to prevent
this one from being
red when that one's blue.
And all the pairwise things you
don't want to have happen, just
make them not happen.
So you can imagine, of course,
much more general gadgets
than this.
We're probably doing much
more than 3-coloring,
but again, all we need
are the xors and the NAND.
So that proves Push-1X
is NP complete for free,
and this approach has been
used by a couple of papers.
So here is another one, Push-1G.
This is pushing
blocks with gravity.
So imagine-- this happens
in a lot of games--
when you're pushing
a block, the block
will fall if it ever
has a hole below it.
Let's say that you
don't fall though,
or you could do lots of
jumps, or flying, or whatever.
You can do something to avoid.
I don't think we'll need any
big jumps for this to work.
So there are lots
of video games that
follow these kinds of roles.
Here's a one-way in that model,
you just push this block over,
it will fall.
So you can't push
it the other way,
but once you push it
forward, it's open
and we're going to denote
that with an arrow.
This is Eric Friedman.
And here is an xor crossover.
This is kind of fun.
If I come in this way,
I push this guy over,
it falls down
blocking that path,
but I can still go through here,
and if I push this one over,
the block falls, and
I can go this way,
but I'm blocked from going
this way or that way.
So that, again, works as
long as I'm only doing
one of the two traversals.
We have a fork gadget,
which is familiar.
If you're coming out from
here, you can push this over
and then you'd be prevented
from going the other way
because you, again, only have
strength 1, and symmetrically
the other side.
Then the NAND ga-- Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For the xor crossover,
you said you couldn't-- When
you're going from
the bottom one,
you push that over and it falls,
and then you can't go back up
because you couldn't
push that block?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I maybe need a wiggle here.
AUDIENCE: The arrow is already
representing one-way gadgets?
PROFESSOR: Good.
That's already here because
the arrow is a one-way.
I forgot the notation.
Yeah.
It's not the input
and the output.
This is an actual one-way.
Good.
OK.
And here's a fun thing I
learned from reading this paper,
you don't even
need a NAND gadget,
because you can simulate a NAND
gadget with xor crossovers.
This is kind of like Jason's
idea of using the crossover
gadget to make copies.
If you traverse through this
way, and through this way,
we know that's possible,
and if you have a set up
where, by going
through a crossover
you block the other traversal--
so that would be a true xor
crossover-- Once I've
pushed this one over,
if I tried to go through
this way down to here,
I would hit the block
here that had fallen
from there and vice versa.
So if it actually prevents
the second traversal,
and in Push-1X, it also
prevented the second traversal
because we had
non-crossing paths.
We weren't allowed to
revisit the same square,
so there it was really trivial.
Here with gravity, it's
a little more subtle,
because the second time
you come through maybe you
could go back that way.
But the key thing is that the
second time you go through,
you won't be able to go through
in the regular crossover way,
and then you just string
two of them together
and you can either traverse
this way or traverse this way,
and each one will
block the other.
So in the end, you just
need a one-way, fork, an xor
crossover, and some kind of
notion of sequential traversal
and you can simulate 3-coloring.
So this is fun.
I haven't seen this
technique used too much,
but in a few papers and
maybe we can use it for more.
Cool.
I didn't mention, but the Push-1
proofs that we saw before,
lecture four or whatever,
revisit the same square
many times.
So we can't use those
proofs for Push-1X.
All the gadgets break.
The next problem I
want to talk about
is a little different,
another graph problem.
It's called graph orientation.
Kind of like edge coloring, but
the colors differ on each side.
So a graph orientation.
This is a pretty recent problem.
It was introduced in 2012,
but I think it's very cool
and deserves much more study.
So you're given an
undirected graph
and you want to find an
orientation-- orientation
means for every
edge, you give it
a direction-- satisfying
certain vertex constraints,
and there are three types of
vertices, three types of vertex
constraints.
They are 1-in-3,
2-in-3, and 0 or 3.
They all end in 3.
I didn't mention, this
is a 3 regular graph.
Every vertex has
degree 3, and so
if you look at an orientation,
every vertex either
has 3 in, 0 out, 2 in, 1 out,
1 in, 2 out, or 0 in, 3 out.
And this problem is NP hard.
Here is a simple
reduction from 3SAT.
That's right, 1 in 3SAT.
So we're going to have
a variable gadget, which
is just this loop of
a cycle in the graph.
And for each of
these vertices that's
a solid black
circle is a 0 or 3.
So that means in any
solution-- here's
a solution-- you're going
to alternate between all in
and all out, and
then all in, all out.
So this is going to
represent x and x-bar.
What the parity of that
cycle is is up to you,
you could either make all the
x's all in or all the x-bars
all in, and that corresponds
to x being true or false.
I think in means
false in this case.
And then for the clauses, we're
going to use a 1 in 3 gadget.
It's because that's
a 1 in 3SAT clause.
We want exactly one
of these three things
to be in coming to the clause.
That gives us exactly one
of them being set to true.
Now, here we're
allowing negations.
We know that's not
necessary for 1 in 3SAT,
but we can in this proof, so
they're drawn here anyway.
But to make it a little bit
weird, one issue in this style,
or in this reduction,
really I just want
a whole bunch of copies of x.
But I get all these
copies of x-bar,
and I need to put
them somewhere.
Every vertex has
to have degree 3,
so this has to go to something.
And so their solution for
doing that is for every clause,
we also build the anti-clause
and make it false.
So we want exactly two
of the negated versions
of these variables
to be set to true.
That's the same thing as exactly
one of the positive forms
of them being true.
Yes.
So we just negate
everything in the clause,
and then wherever we use x, we
also use x-bar and vice versa.
So that guarantees that we
use up all of these instances.
If there are k
occurrences of x, then
we'll make k
occurrences of x-bar
and make them all used by the
corresponding anti-clauses.
So this is why we need those
three types of gadgets.
If we're doing a
problem in the plane,
we'll also need a
crossover for this to work.
But at this point, it's
just a graph problem.
OK?
So that's cool.
And this problem was
introduced in order
to solve a packing problem.
A little bit of
history, some time ago,
I think the '70s, there
was a paper about,
if I give you polygon
some orthogonal polygon
shape with holes in it,
and I want to pack as many,
say, 3 by 3 squares in the
polygon, that's NP hard.
If I want to pack as many 2
by 2 squares, that's NP hard.
That was a later paper, and so
how much smaller of a square
can you make?
Well, a 1 by 1 square, that's
pretty easy, in a grid polygon.
How many 1 by 1
squares can I pack?
The area.
In a grid polygon, how
many 2 by 1 rectangles
can I pack this way or this way?
That's maximum
cardinality matching.
So the next thing
left is trominoes.
Three squares, and they
could be in an L-shape
or they could be in an I-shape.
Here, we're thinking about
both problems separately.
So suppose you have a whole
bunch of L-shaped packages
that you want to fit into this
weirdly shaped warehouse, that
is NP hard.
It's even hard in the
exact packing case.
There will be no
holes-- Sorry, there
will be no gaps in this packing.
Every unit square
will be filled,
and I think that's
quite particular.
Those other proofs of packing,
the 2 by 2 and the 3 by 3
squared into a polygon,
I should have shown them,
but they're from
3SAT, planar 3SAT.
They leave gaps
all over the place.
Here, you don't leave
gaps and I think
it's somehow fundamental to
this graph orientation business.
So here is the idea of for an
edge in that graph orientation
problem.
It's basically a rectangle
with a bump every other square.
So this is a big hole.
You're not allowed to
put anything down there.
And the idea is
you can either have
the L's all pointing
to the right
or all pointing to the left.
And so you think of these
as kind of the communication
position.
One of these will correspond to
the edge pointing to the right,
one will correspond to the
edges pointing to the left.
And you can build a turn gadget.
It works pretty cleanly.
It doesn't matter whether
this is covered by that guy
or covered by that guy.
It behaves the same
as a regular wire.
So again, it's either
this or this is occupied,
exactly one of them.
That tells you the
orientation of the edge.
So that's an edge.
You can also build a crossover.
This is a little more casework.
But again, this is
occupied if and only
if this is not occupied, and
this is occupied if and only
all combinations are possible.
We just need to check that there
is a valid packing no matter
which of those choices you want.
Either left and top being empty,
or left and bottom being empty,
or top and right being empty,
or bottom and right being empty.
Those are the four cases.
Cool.
Crossover.
Now we need the 0 and
3, 1 and 3, and 2 and 3.
So instead of a single 0 or
3, they built two in a row.
I don't know if
this is required,
but it's fine for the
proof, because in the proof
it was always XI, XI-Bar,
so there are always
2, 0, or 3's in a
row, and there it is.
So in this setting,
essentially either the left two
will have bumps and the right
two will not have bombs,
or vice versa, the right
two will have bumps.
This corresponds to
these guys all being out
in all three directions,
and these guys
all being in all three
directions, or vice versa,
and these are all out
and these are all in.
So that's the x or x-bar.
And this gadget does it.
Again, check the cases.
We have exactly 1-in-3.
If exactly 1 of these is in,
then this will be packable,
and otherwise it won't.
That's the part that's hard
to show but you check it.
And if you want a
2-in-3 gadget, you just
add a couple more blocks
right there and it works.
So that's it.
Once you have all those gadgets,
you can do graph orientation
and then you're NP hard.
That was for L-trominoes.
Do the same thing
for I-trominoes.
This is hard to see where the
bold lines are, but if you look
and if you download the slide,
it's probably a little easier
to see, but, again,
you can build.
Here, an edge gadget is
fairly straightforward.
Just wiggle a path and
you'll either have it--
These wiggles are in
order to guarantee--
There's actually three possible
parities you could have.
Sticking out by 1, or sticking
out by 2 with an I-gadget.
This will force it to be
just 1 or 0, because we
don't want it to be 2.
And then the crossover
is ugly, but it works.
And the 0, 3, and the
1-in-3 are not too hard.
And do I have the 2 in?
I think this is a 2-in-3,
I didn't label it.
So, presumably, for any
polynomial shape you want,
you can build such
gadgets so that we
don't have such a theorem,
but I think this is neat.
It's a little different from
a lot of the other proofs,
similar to one of the
problem set problems
where we had some constraints
on the neighboring things.
But instead of about constraints
on the neighboring colors
of the vertices or
whatever, or the truth
assignments in the vertices,
here, it's an edge direction.
So the edge directions are
interesting because, first
of all, there's only
two choices, but also
that what you see on one
side is the opposite of what
you see on the other side.
Questions?
So that is graph orientation,
and I have one more
set of problems I
want to talk about.
They have many names, but
the general family is usually
called something like
linear layout of a graph,
and it's a bijection--
let's call it
f-- from the vertices to 1
up to the number of vertices.
So in other words, I'm thinking
of a one dimensional diagram
and the coordinates I have
are 1, 2, up to the number
of vertices and I just
want to put exactly one
vertex at each of these spots.
So I basically want a
permutation of the vertices,
and then I slap them
down in that order,
and then I measure
something about the quality
of that layout
based on the edges.
We haven't involved edges yet.
And there are many different
measures you might consider.
Here are many of them,
but without definitions.
So let me tell you
some definitions.
So the first one, of the
earliest to be considered,
is called bandwidth.
Bandwidth is, if you look at an
edge, one endpoint of the edge
gets mapped to one coordinate
and the other endpoint gets
mapped to another coordinate.
You can measure the length of
that edge in the embedding.
I shouldn't call it embedding
because it's non-crossing,
but in the layout.
So for some edge vw, you can
measure the length of the edge.
If I want to minimize the
maximum length of any edge,
that is bandwidth.
Why is it called bandwidth?
Anyone know?
No one does matrices anymore,
or numerical linear algebra,
so I'll tell you why.
If you have a matrix, let's
say, of 0's and 1's-- that's a
graph, of course-- and all
of the non-zero elements are
in that band, then we
call this bandwidth w.
If it's 0 out here
and 0 out here.
Why are these interesting?
Because then if you run
Gaussian elimination,
you always stay within the band.
So this is some of the
early approaches to solving
sparse linear systems.
If you can get all of
the 0's into the corners,
then you can focus here,
especially if your tri-diagonal
is a common case.
Anyway, that's called bandwidth,
and what this problem is saying
is I'm allowed to permute the
rows and columns of my matrix
in order to minimize how
many diagonals I need to use.
So that is permutation
to minimize bandwidth.
It would be great,
except it's NP hard.
It's NP hard even on
trees of maximum degree 3.
It's NP hard even
on caterpillars.
Almost caterpillars.
A caterpillar is a graph,
something like this.
I think this is caterpillar
with hair length
at most 3, so these may
be paths of a length 3,
maybe they even
branch a little bit,
but every vertex is within
distance 3 of a single path.
So even for such graphs,
when mapped into matrices,
this problem is NP hard.
Lots of cases are NP hard,
even for good graphs.
You might think of
that as more general,
but it's not
immediately implied.
OK.
Cool.
That was bandwidth.
Next one, which I've seen used
in a few different hardness
proofs, is minimum
linear arrangement.
Almost the same problem,
but instead of taking
the maximum edge length and
trying to minimize that,
take the sum of the edge lengths
and try to minimize that.
That's minimum
linear arrangement.
We will see a reduction
from that in a moment.
It's NP hard, even for
my bipartite graphs.
Cut width.
This is, you draw all the
edges as horizontal segments
and then I come in
with a vertical line
and see how many
edges can I cross.
I want to find a permutation,
so I minimize the maximums,
you might call it
stabbing width.
The maximum number
of edges that cross
from the left side
to the right side
where I take the maximum
over all notions of side.
I take the maximum over all
choices of this x-coordinate,
and I want to
minimize that maximum.
That is cut width.
Why do I want to minimize
the maximum as opposed to,
say, minimizing the sum
of those cut values?
Because that's the same as
minimum linear arrangement.
If I minimize the sum
of all of these cuts,
that's the same thing
as minimizing the sum
of the lengths of the edges.
So that's the same problem.
So, OK.
We got rid of one.
That was cut width.
It's hard for planar
graphs, max degree
3, good graphs, lots of things.
I'm going to skip mod cut.
That's just a slight different
variation on that definition.
Next one is vertex separation.
OK.
This is a different
way of counting.
So here, I was counting
how many edges cross,
but maybe many of those edges
come from the same vertex.
I don't want to double
count those, let's say.
I just want to count how many
vertices on the left side
have at least one edge that
goes to the right side,
and only count it once instead
of three times in this picture.
OK?
Otherwise the same
problem as cut width.
That is also hard.
That problem is different if
you look at the sum versions.
You can account for
every partition point
how many vertices in the left
have an edge to the right side,
sum that over all
of these x values,
and then that is sum cut.
All of these have been
considered in various contexts.
Last one is edge by section.
This is where you only look at
cutting in the middle at v/2.
So you want to balance partition
all the things on the left,
you want to have very few
edges to things on the right.
Or the vertex version
where you want
to minimize number
vertices on the left
and edges to the right
half, but exactly half. v/2.
v/2.
A ton of problems.
I mentioned them
so that if you ever
run into a problem about
ordering vertices on a line,
you should look at
all of those and see
which one is the most useful.
Sort of like we have
3SAT and 1 and 3SAT,
and not-all-equal-SAT Choose
the one that's easiest for you.
If you have some kind
of ordering problem,
choose the one that's
easiest for you.
Good to know that
these are out there.
They come from
various applications.
Cut width is studied
a lot in graph theory,
graph minor stuff.
It's closely related
to path width.
Some of these
problem-- The bisection
comes from numerical
linear algebra.
Minimum linear arrangement
comes, I think, originally
from VLSI layout, chip design.
It's like a very simple version.
If you just have a bunch
of ports on the bottom
and you know that
certain things need
to be connected by
wires, that's your graph,
you want to minimize the
total amount of wire stuff
you have to-- minimize
the total wire lengths.
So that's minimum
linear arrangement.
Very simple version of some
kind of VLSI layout problem.
And there's this survey if you
want to see all these problems.
There's one problem
not on the survey
because it's not about a
graph, it's about a hypergraph,
but it's a useful one.
Among ordering problems,
it's the one I know the best.
I've tried to use
it a couple times,
but rarely have I succeeded in
getting an actual NP hardness
proof from it, but
I will show you one,
and it is called betweenness.
So in this case, I'm
given a bunch of triples,
a set of pairs of things-- it's
not a graph-- of the form y
is between x and z.
And what that means
is either it's
between x and z in
that sense, or it's
the other sense,
where either x is to the left
of z or z is to the left of x,
but y is always between.
And here, of course, I really
mean f of x and f of y.
I mean them in the
linear embedding.
OK.
So you're given a bunch
of triples like this,
and then you want to find a
linear layout of your letters.
So again, that's a
bijection from 1 to n,
and such that these all hold.
So there's no objective
function to minimize here.
It's just you want each of
these things to be true.
So this is nice, because it's
a pretty clean constraint
and yet, it's hard.
If I, for example,
was just giving
you-- If I gave you a bunch of
inequality constraints, like x
is less than y.
That's easy.
That's sorting a partial order.
But here, you have a
little bit of ambiguity.
You don't know how
x and z relate.
You just know that y
is in between them.
That's enough to get hardness.
So I'm not going to prove
any of those problems hard,
but I will show you two
examples of hardness proofs.
First one is going to be from
the minimum linear arrangement.
In case you haven't
already memorized
all the problems I just
described, let me remind you.
Minimum linear
arrangement was minimize
the sum of the edge lengths.
That was the second
problem I described,
that was like the VLSI layout.
Minimize the sum of
all the red lines.
Find the permutation
that does that.
So we're going to
reduce it first
to a problem called
bipartite crossing number.
It's a bit of a weird problem.
It's mostly a stop gap on the
way to another problem, which
is crossing number.
Suppose you're given
bipartite a graph, which
is hard to see in this picture.
Given a bipartite graph, and
you want to draw in the plane.
So I have some
bipartite graph, I
want to draw it in the
plane in a special way.
I want all of the vertices
in one side of bipartition
to be on a horizontal line.
I want all the vertices in the
other side of the bipartition
to be on a parallel
horizontal line.
And all the edges
are in between.
They're straight lines.
And I want to minimize
the number of crossings.
So it's this very specific
kind of graph layout problem,
but minimizing number of
crossing is clearly good.
We want to draw as
planar as possible.
So here is a reduction from
minimum linear arrangement
to bipartite crossing number.
So in this problem, we're
given a general graph, not
necessarily bipartite.
We want to convert it
into a bipartite graph.
How do we do that?
Make two copies of every vertex.
OK, so for every vertex in
the minimum linear arrangement
problem, we're going to
make two copies called
bottom one and top one, top
two and bottom two, bottom
two and top two, and so on.
So there's n top vertices
and bottom vertices,
and I'm going to do two things.
One is connect a
whole bunch of edges.
And a whole bunch
means e squared,
and between bottom I and
top I. I just do that.
That will basically
force this kind of layout
where, basically,
the order on the top
has to be identical to
the order on the bottom.
Because if ever any of these
two bundles of edges crossed,
you would get e to
the fourth crossings.
And so if you ever
want to get less than e
to the fourth
crossings-- and that's
what we will hopefully
do-- then these
must appear same order
on top and bottom.
But we don't know
what the order is.
You can still permute
the bottom, just
correspondingly permute
the top, and all
be well as far as
these edge bundles go.
So that's good, because it
has exactly the flexibility,
we have exactly one
permutation on n things.
That's what we want
to represent with
minimum linear arrangement.
Then the only other
thing we do is
add in the edges of the graph.
But in the minimum linear
arrangement problem,
the edges are like
from vertex I to vertex
J. We're going to make that
connection from bottom I to top
J. There's this choice, but it
doesn't matter which is which.
So the idea is, then, that edge
will cross a bunch of bundles.
The number of bundles
it crosses is the length
of the edge minus 1, I think.
I'll ignore these
additive constants.
You have to be careful to
make sure everything adds up
the right way.
If you have a link
0 edge-- We never
have the link 0 edge,
because vertices
map to different places.
If you have a length 1 edge,
you won't cross anything,
so 0 crossings.
If you have a length 2 edge, you
will cross exactly one bundle,
and you pay e squared for that.
In general, it will
be something like e
squared times the sum of
the lengths of the edges.
Not exactly.
You have to subtract
off some things,
but you just compute
what that is.
It will always be basically
some fixed constant times
the minimum linear
arrangement cost,
which was the sum of the lengths
of the edges plus some fixed
constant.
And so you can solve the
bipartite crossing number
with a given specified number
of crossings if and only
if you can solve minimum linear
arrangement with a specified
sum of edge lengths.
Question.
AUDIENCE: What about the
crossing between edges?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
There's also crossings
between edges,
and you have to count them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] because
you can't get more than e
squared with this
in the normal case?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that will be in the noise.
The bulk of the
number of crossings
will be from crossing the
bundles with the single edges.
You don't want to have
bundle-bundle crossings.
Those, you can never afford.
So you're basically counting
bundles versus single edges.
The total number of
single edge crossings
will be strictly
less than e squared,
and so it will be strictly
less than a single guy
crossing a bundle.
So you have to inflate.
It's not an exact
counting, because you
don't know how many of
those single edge crossings
you're going to get.
So you have to add
almost e squared.
I have the exact count here.
I don't know how
interesting it is.
But what they wrote, it's
e squared times k minus e,
plus 1 minus 1 is the
exact number in the paper.
k here is the sum of the lengths
of the edges in that problem.
This is, I think, the minus 1
per edge, that gets multiplied
by e squared, and then
we're basically adding
e squared minus 1 at the end.
So almost e squared to allow
for any number of crossings
between the single guys.
It does make a lot of sense.
OK.
So that was bipartite
crossing number,
but the more natural
problem, I would say,
is I give you a
graph, I want to draw
on the plane with
fewest crossings.
That is, crossing number,
and it's a reduction
from the previous problem.
So basically, you can
force these vertices
to be on a horizontal
line, and these vertices
to be on another
horizontal line,
and to only have
edges between here
and here by adding huge bundles
out here to basically prevent
anything from going out there,
Now we're given a
bipartite graph.
We want to draw it
in this kind of way,
minimizing number of
crossings in between.
And so this will turn
that into a general graph.
It's actually still bipartite,
but now the planar embedding
is forced, more or less.
I mean, it's not an embedding.
I keep using that word.
The planar drawing is
more or less forced.
You can show these guys have
to be in this kind of topology,
and then there's some
crossings in here,
but none of these edges
could ever cross this,
because this is way more
than the number of crossings
in the input graph.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What about
not multi-graphs?
PROFESSOR: Not multi-graphs?
Good question.
I assume you can split
these things up, or maybe
subdivide the edges,
or some trick,
but I have to be very careful.
I don't know for sure.
Definitely not
mentioned in this paper.
OK.
So that was crossing number,
bipartite, and unconstraints.
And I have one more sketch of a
proof, which is mostly for fun,
and I get to use
my favorite phrase,
how to kill log n birds with
one stone, or order one stones.
So suppose you have
a Rubik's cube,
but 3, by 3, by 3, that's easy.
So you have an n, by n, by
n Rubik's cube, like this 7,
by 7, by 7, v cube, and
moves are-- I assume you all
know how a Rubik's cube works.
You can rotate in each
of these directions--
and I hope not to
mess it up too much--
and your goal is to get to the
state where it's all solved.
Now, usually, someone's
mean, and they mix it all up,
and they just give it
you like, OK solve it.
I don't just want
to solve it, I want
to solve it with
the fewest moves,
because it's polynomial
time to solve it at all.
I want to solve it
in the fewest moves.
So if I'm given this
position, I want
to know it's only one
move away from solved.
We do not know the
complexity of that problem.
Let me first tell you a nice
way to think about this problem
is actually in the 2D case.
So these are not
built super large,
but, again, I can rotate
either a row or a column.
So at a high level, you can
think of a picture like this.
You have a red side
and a blue side,
and there's a certain--
If you think about where
this square goes, it
can go to this position,
to this position,
and this position.
In general, a
little cube can only
go to four different
spots in 2D.
On the 3D cube,
there's 24 spots it
can go to, because there are
24 automorphisms on the cube.
It's just a lot harder to
see, but it's essentially
the same thing going on.
So here's a sort of
thing you could do.
If I flip this column,
these guys go over to here,
and they flip upside down.
So whatever was red here
becomes blue down here,
and it gets reflected
across this line.
So when I do this move,
I get this pattern
for that row, that column.
If I also do it at this
column, I get that pattern.
OK.
So now maybe I do
these two columns.
They completely flip,
become all blue.
Now maybe I do these two
columns and I get this picture
because these red spots become
blue up here, and so on.
And then if I flip these two
rows, hey, I solved the puzzle.
And in general, if you look at
a [? cubee ?] and the four other
[? cubees ?] that it can go
to, they have some pattern.
There's a constant number
patterns they can have.
For 2D it's-- I forget-- like
10 or 20 different patterns.
In 3D, it's, like, a lot more.
Billions or something.
Anyway.
But it's constant, even
for an n, by n, by n cube.
So you can characterize
for each such pattern
what it needs to be solved.
So these [? cubees ?],
for example,
need a column, row, column, row.
That's what we showed.
We flipped its column,
then we flipped its row,
then we flipped its column,
then we flipped its row.
That solved it.
That's exactly what they need.
And in minimal solution,
you will do that.
But what you see
here is, suppose
I had a big grid of them.
I could do all the columns, then
all the rows containing them,
then all of the columns
and all the rows.
If they were in the
same initial pattern,
I get a big savings in how
quickly I can solve it.
If I have an x by y grid
of identically oriented
[? cubees ?], I can
solve it in about x
plus y moves instead
of x times y moves.
And this is something we used to
prove that you can solve an n,
by n, by n Rubik's cube and n
squared divided by log n moves,
in the worst case.
So you can kill log n
birds with one stone.
There's always such a grid
of area roughly log n.
But here, I want to use
that idea for hardness.
In some sense, that was to
give you some intuition.
Sadly, we don't know whether
this problem is NP hard,
minimizing the number
of moves, but what
we do know is that if
some of the stickers
fell off your cube,
then it's NP hard.
So the white things
here don't care.
You don't care what
state they end up in.
They're sort of
wild cards, so it
could be the sticker
came off or maybe
it just changes its
color to whatever's
correct at the moment.
But some of the
stickers are still on
and they have to be
solved, and this is
a reduction from betweenness.
This gadget will be solvable
in a certain number of moves
if and only if the first time
you make the x2 column move
is between the first time
you make the x1 column
move and the x3 column move.
I think these are
in the situation
that they want to do
column, row, column, row,
something like that.
So each one's going
to get used twice.
It's a matter of how you
intersperse those orders.
So it's an ordering problem, and
this ends up being betweenness.
I will not go through the proof.
It's quite tedious.
So this column is going
to get used many times
in the reduction.
Basically, you just work
in the upper left corner
of the picture because the
other quarters move similarly.
You introduce some
extra rows and columns
that are specific to
this betweenness gadget,
and if you want to have
more betweenness gadgets,
you add more such columns
and rows in this pattern.
As long as they're sort of
off diagonal from each other,
they won't interact, hence you
end up with a big betweenness
reduction.
So that's it for today.